alright grammarian so we know that
there's one way to use this thing we
call reflexive pronouns and that's to
say you're doing something to yourself
as in the sentence I made myself
breakfast right I'm making myself
breakfast or in the sentence Reynaldo
cut himself shaving sorry about the
capitalist there that is a mistake
so Ronaldo and himself and I and myself
we use these are called reflexive
pronouns and we use them when the
subject and the object of a sentence is
the same thing right but there's another
way to use these reflexive pronouns and
it's called emphatic usage so I want you
to imagine me storming off in a huff or
getting really excited as I say the
following well if you won't help me I'll
do it myself
or he's lying I heard it myself or the
princess herself is running the charity
marathon and what this is is what we
call emphatic or intensive because we
use it to intensify a statement or to
grant it emphasis right this is this is
how it works so instead of just saying
and the difference the key difference
between reflexive and intensive or
emphatic usage of this kind of pronoun
as you could take these right out of a
sentence and would still make sense I'll
do it I heard it the princess will run
the marathon right we're using them as
intensifiers
which really means they can come right
out they're not essential to the
understanding of the sentence you're
just using these words
in order to hammer home a point you know
if someone else isn't helping you you
say I'll do it but you want to really
hammer home the fact that you're going
to be doing it alone so you say I'll do
it myself and if you want to emphasize
that you were you were there and you
heard something happen you would say I
heard it myself and if it's really crazy
that the princess is running this
marathon then you would say whoa the
princess herself will be there and
that's that's nuts and that's the
intensive or emphatic pronoun that's how
you use it you can learn anything Dave
it out